this is a production of cornell
university
well uh thanks everybody our live
attendees who are hanging in there in
the spring for for tuning in this is
episode 17
the cornell turk show fastest 30 minutes
in turf
today's guest dr andy mcmitt of penn
state university uh and who knows what
we'll talk about today you know
we uh we might go through a bunch of
different topics we'll see maybe we'll
get a little debate here between
dr rossi and dr mcnitt but um as always
before we get into maybe the battle of
of the professors we'll have a little
bit overview from uh frank to start us
off here
i got no chance in the battle of
professors
i think i think the western pa uh uh
philadelphia guy is gonna kick my butt
every time so
thanks for joining us andy let me get
started here i'll take about five or six
minutes to talk a little bit about the
weather
ask you a couple of questions and then i
we can have a wide ranging conversation
it's
really appreciate you taking the 30
minutes and carl and i now know
we can in fact bend the space-time
continuum
and make time make 30 minutes feel even
faster so
uh just a big shout out to our cornell
alum
uh jc treader who will be part of the
conversation uh
later today and and just again andy to
shout out to you and all the colleagues
uh all the professional sports turf
managers
that got together to develop this bmp
document and i think carl
it's time for us to start doing tips of
the week with this
uh moving forward this is just a such a
wonderful
document uh national document for
everybody to look at
uh that i think is just really the kind
of leadership that this
uh discipline needed i i think to bring
especially the guys who do the work the
guys and gals are doing the work
to be viewed as professional that there
is a science behind what they do
and i i just love the fact that this
publication's out there now so big shout
out to
to you andy and everybody else involved
let's talk a little bit about the
weather
um just what you can see going on
through most of our the northeast
is it's really in a bit of a stall and
it looks like that stall's going to
continue
if you look at growing degree days
except for the balmy buffalo and
eerie pennsylvania region of north of
the northeast
most folks are right at normal now
certainly
south jersey philly uh there certainly
and delmarva is still a week or two
ahead and that's where that gradient
is going to be uh above and below normal
temperatures but
you know i woke up to 35 degrees in
frost today and i know my brother r d
guytano told me to stick a fork in
winter but
i think i i i think we gotta have to
reconsider the jinxing of that comment
we are expected to be below normal for
next weekend for the foreseeable future
and again that is leading to
unabated turf growth i mean this is a
time of year when the grass is just
going to be growing like crazy i often
say
you can't grow grass at this time of the
year it's time to consider
another line of work because when you
look at the
precipitation most of the areas that
were dry
in the past are now well above normal
particularly that center swath
throughout the northeastern u.s a little
bit drier
along the coast but i was on long island
and the grasses were not looking dry
down there this early this week
and again for the foreseeable future
we're expected to be slightly above
normal with precipitation as well so
again you know you're going to have good
grass growing not
ideal maybe a little bit cooler but
certainly to the south of the region a
little bit better
you can see soil temperatures really
starting to come on but we expect these
to stall a little bit
both the combination of the rainfall and
increasing temperatures and of course
you know anybody in the sports world's
got
probably another piece of ground that
they're taking care of
and you'll notice i think the tree
people would call this a massed
year for a particular plant but this
would be a mass year
for dandelions particularly a lot of
places that had to skip
maybe fall control maybe turf management
practices got depleted last year
uh for for covid and and just budget
reductions overall
and now you're looking at a sea of these
things we're seeing guys uh actively try
to drop the mowing height just to get
the flowers off of there so you can't
see them
but again i don't uh believe that you
know a field of dandelions
is going to be ideal uh for the kinds of
sport
field you know focused active
recreational activity when you got a lot
when you got a field cover in these
kinds of things and we're going to talk
about you know
safety in a little bit obviously that
becomes a big issue so
you know if you have the ability to do
control recon you know control
there's two uh types of chemistries that
you reach for one is an amine
formulation of 240 the other is an ester
formulation of 240.
and you see very little but subtle
differences
in these two models that are predicting
the best time for spring control now
keep in mind this is not the ideal time
to control these plants
it's what we do because we see them now
but really fall
applications of these products even late
into
october november when you're still above
50 degrees you can get really good
deep control of these uh broadleaf weeds
with
a lot of a lot of broadleaf herbicides
will do the trick but in the spring
we've embraced this growing degree day
model
looking at base 50 growing degree day
accumulation since the middle of march
and you can see the ester form is pretty
good up into the hudson valley and into
the
balmy buffalo region but still the amine
formulation taking a little bit of time
to catch up
and then as soon as it starts to get
warm you want to move away from the
ester formulation because it's a little
more volatile when temperatures get high
so you'll move to a more
at the amine formulation if you're going
to do spring control
i'd recommend that you keep track of
this on the forecast model
now of course since we're talking weeds
and growth uh
obviously crabgrass germination is still
considered to be at the
upper end of early for most of us uh you
can see germination is actively
occurring
throughout uh the metropolitan new york
area across to where andy's at in
central pa and then you can see the
mountains take over
and the elevations are slowing
germination a little bit but we're
starting to see
pretty regular germination of crabgrass
throughout the region so if you were not
using
pre-emergent herbicides or you start to
see some plants
now is the opportunity to go out and
start doing your spot treating
we've had some success with spot
treating things like fiesta
when you get fiesta down uh i'm you know
not labeled for it currently i think it
might be labeled for suppression
but chelated iron is not allowed under
the safe playing fields act so you're
going to have to ask for an exemption
for the rest of you obviously that's a a
pretty reduced risk
option for even for early post-crab
grass control if you've
not used any pre-emergence control now
as i welcome
our guest and my long-time pal who i've
had the pleasure of sharing a couple of
good italian dinners with he still owes
me a dinner i think in philly at some
point
and i'm gonna get that out of him but i
wanna i always like to have andy on and
maybe he thinks like we talk about the
same things all the time but
i went back to the website andy and saw
the synthetic turf research site you've
got there and boy do you
have a plethora of information and you
know i don't know how i missed this but
in 2019
uh you put this particular if you were
involved in this particular publication
that uh really looked at what i thought
was really sort of
wonderful about synthetic turf and also
that
this conclusion right on the first page
of it where you say
you know it requires routine maintenance
even at the level of local athletics and
this
is so critical for the conversation when
we talk to
you know average uh grounds guys who are
taking care of
synthetic turf surfaces this idea that
somewhat
it's low maintenance so so here's where
you know here's where you can decide
whether you want to say anything or not
but because it was a cornell guy the
head of the nfl players association came
out
uh really uh i think forcefully uh
and said you know listen uh we gotta get
rid of these synthetic surfaces
uh grass uh and i think it's things
we've talked about in the past where
grass gives
uh where maybe synthetic turf doesn't
now that might be related to this
footwear i
i think this obviously is going to need
some clarification
uh you know there's a number of things
that came up this past year or
metlife stadium this this sort of made
uh
quite a hubbub and then recently
just the other day uh the panthers
announced with the
arrival of the charlotte team to play in
that space
to go to synthetic turf and you know i i
think this is really interesting this
guy at the bottom mark hart promises to
maintain
uh field quality and i think it speaks
to um
you know a contact i received recently
from a lawyer
uh through our sports fields website uh
you know defective artificial turf and i
just draw you back andy as i bring you
in pal
you know you you know you were involved
in this and in this document
are these wonderful synthetic turf uh
guidelines and i'm sure you were you
were involved in this
even best management practices for these
things so
you know i would just really make sure
if you're in the sports turf
business that you're aware of this
document
that you've got it on your bookshelf
that you've got a link to it
uh on your uh phone or somewhere
because not only do i think does this
help you
but i also think it helps you
communicate these things
because oftentimes grounds managers or i
think are in positions where
they've really got to explain and
educate the people
you know what it is they're doing so
andy and big thanks to ben i i know
there's a picture
uh here's the photograph that ben has in
the bmp document
you know and again andy i'm happy to go
lots of different ways pal
but but you know just some simple
considerations for communities
considering synthetic turf
key aspects of care and the rising
chorus of concern so
let me leave it at that pal look at you
again and see what kind of trouble i'm
in
uh now that i've done you know
uh it's uh it's philadelphia versus uh
new york right the bronx versus manny
young that's right
so uh i don't know the flyers versus the
bruins
oh let's go brother yeah so um
yeah obviously those bmps were a huge
team effort and i had a small part of it
but yeah i had some input on the
synthetic and some other sections
uh and it's a good start it's hard to
figure out where to stop with bmps right
because you're just scratching the
surface
right but you know my one bone to pick
with you is good every time i have you
all
you have me on here you want to talk
about synthetic i mean this time you
fooled me we're supposed to talk about
multi-use high school fields and all of
a sudden we're talking about synthetic
again
and i guess i'm a synthetic expert
because the one-eyed man is
king in the land of the blind right um
nobody else knows anything and i know a
little bit so suddenly i'm the big
expert
um i mean when it comes to synthetic
turf you know one of the big issues when
a school's thinking about putting it in
is this whole water issue
and you know is it a pervious surface or
is it impervious
and i got you know you got to really
think about this a little bit
so we got a natural soil high school
field out there that's compacted what do
you think it's perking at frank
quarter of an inch an hour maybe right
most of that water's running off
now i've got a synthetic turf field
that's perking at 75 inches per hour
and it's called impervious and the
natural grass is called pervious
now the argument is made well all the
water that goes through that synthetic
ends up in the storm sewer system but
the
the question is does it all i mean it
has soil at the bottom of that gravel
too right that water's going to lay
there and permeate in and as a matter of
fact since that soil
after it goes through some freeze-thaw
cycles probably is permeable
and we have and so each individual
district has its own rules there's no
statewide rules there
almost aren't even county-wide rules in
pennsylvania it tends to be
you know locale by locale and you have
to make the argument
we have seen not that many but i've seen
uh
systems go in where they made the gravel
deeper they moved the pipes up in the
gravel so now you have a retention base
and in almost all the water that goes
there
unless you have some gigantic storm
almost all the water is going to
percolate back down into the groundwater
system so
why do i bring this up school districts
can save some money
if you get an architect who can argue
that to the
local government and say look this is
actually a pervious surface you can save
an awful lot of money on permitting
anyway so that was one of the big issues
we took on with the bmps
um you know if you want to talk about
synthetic turf in the nfl
so you know we continue to look at it
and we look at these injuries and we see
these numbers floating around the paper
we put out
two years ago that said 19 more injuries
if you play unnatural as opposed to
synthetic
in the nfl over the last six years and
that's true
if uh you know if 100
of the fields were synthetic versus 100
of the fields were natural
but you know now we're about half and
half we still even after carolina
changes
we're still um more natural grass
stadium fields than synthetic
obviously everybody practices on a lot
of natural grass
but when you start to break those
numbers down even closer i mean it
starts to get the reality would be you
know maybe four percent
the numbers start to change a little bit
because not every game
you know would switch from 100 synthetic
to 100 percent natural
shoes play a role trading plays a role i
mean it's the era of big data and the
league
and the players association are looking
at everything
training schedules shoes shoe fit
and so yes the surfaces are important
i'm trained as a natural turf guy i love
natural turf somehow i got slung with
this
synthetic turf expert thing which is
fine because nobody else wanted to pick
up the mantle and i can take the slings
and arrows
seems to me the guys you know if you're
managing this thing you ought to know
something about it
um and and our clientele and our
students and and uh our stakeholders are
out there making
diseases listen listen pal
you don't have to apologize to me
because you know every time i call you
it's to talk about this because i do
think it's our responsibility because as
i've learned
we're involved the same people who
manage natural gras i mean
ben polymers probably imagine managing a
natural grass system and a synthetic
turf system
so we are training these people and i
think it's been a real black hole
both of misperceptions of not knowing
that they need maintenance
and somehow uh this idea that they're
you know that they're we should never
have them and
i've always thought what i've learned
from paying attention to the work that
you've done to what i've seen in my own
life
is that when we go back to multi-use
natural grass fields andy
it our natural grass fields are getting
a lot more
pressure than they've ever had before
that's why the topic of multi-use
natural grass fields come up
but i think it then begs the question in
places where the shoulders of the season
don't have good growth to sustain
uh traffic do synthetic turf surfaces
make
sense as a swing surface to put
athletes on and not a primary surface
where they can still get a lot of access
to natural breath i think the question
is
you know should we have some of both
rather than just saying well let's just
because a lot of kids like to say
in nfl there's 50 50 but i meet kids at
cornell who play on our teams who
haven't never played on a natural grass
surface oh yeah
but that sort of bugs me too pal sure
sure and so
each each situation is unique i can't
say a school should have synthetic i
mean i've consulted at schools
that wanted to put synthetic in and i'm
like this is a stupid idea you want to
take that money
build two more natural grass fields
you're going to be fine other situations
where they're fighting to keep natural
grass and i'm saying
you know man the amount of play with
like battery park in new york city right
they have a clock
if soccer fields there like four of them
they had 22
000 kids signed up for soccer and
they're like we can't keep natural grass
on here i'm like
you can't on route 80 either it's
surprising you know
at some point at some point you got to
say there's another option
uh so so you know the decision
is oftentimes a socio-political decision
and we can only help
so yeah sometimes it's good i mean here
in pennsylvania they want to start
playing baseball march
1. you know and how are you going to do
that on natural grass and if you do
you're probably going to destroy that
field and not give it any time to heal
and it's going to be a mess and so
it's a dynamic complicated picture we're
not there to make the final decision
right frank
we're there to be tech support and say
listen here's the
ideas here's how you got to make your
decision we lead the decision along
look in the nfl what happens is
especially when you get a major league
soccer
team is you're trying to have concerts
all summer too
right and play and play soccer and so
now you're talking about
what nine resods that summer all right
is that what it's gonna
be and so you know that's how the
decision gets made unfortunately
um but i will tell you this there are a
lot of teams in the nfl that are doing
feasibility studies to switch back to
natural grass
and it's my hope that um you know
as time goes by here it's just going to
happen organically
and that means yeah and that means
multi-use facility i mean listen you
know
you guys where you've been involved i i
think you were involved in the vegas
thing where they're rolling the field in
and out
that is one solution to multi-use right
i mean not every community is going to
build something like that
but that is one solution it recognizes
that if you don't limit the use of this
surface
it natural grass has limitations as you
say you can't grow grass on i-80 either
so i do think that's part of the thing
that we're trying to keep the athletes
safe and you got footwear decisions
but we got a pretty good idea there's
only so much traffic these fields can
take you can't put the lights on
and play on them 24 7. so let's talk a
little bit about that for a second
because you raised a good point
a lot of of the rank and file places
have native soil fields
they probably had a lot of use this past
year
what are you telling those places
because they're probably at their last
leg where it's that
a sandbase field or a couple of sand
based fields
or a synthetic field so what are you
telling those people that are on the
edge with those native soils now so the
deal is is that
rarely do i suggest a sand-based field
for a high school
because they don't have the personnel
you know or the expertise to take care
of them and now you're going to pile a
bunch of money into this natural grass
field
it has a good chance of failing there's
a lot less buffer capacity in a natural
grass fee or in a
sand based field and then they're going
to lose it and then the administration
is going to say my god we just spent
500 000 on a natural grass field it
didn't work for 700
000 we can have a rug and we don't have
to think about it anymore so i think
that's a lose-lose
because if you're having trouble with
your natural grass now
you're gonna have more trouble when you
go to sand um the sand-based fields you
know we've done experiments
they don't necessarily if you have
perfect control of the water
right on both the natural and you never
do but on a natural and a
sand-based field if you have perfect
control of the water the natural soil
field
it will wear better than the sand-based
field the sand based field will actually
wear out through abrasion
faster now why do they say a sand based
field is superior
because how much how many games does it
take on a native soil field to ruin it
one rain game right and that's the thing
you're preventing on the sand-based
field is that one disaster game
that destroys the field but otherwise i
think you go native soil
i tell you the biggest thing that these
high schools can do and everybody's
going to go oh man they're going to roll
their eyes
you need more help you need labor right
it's about labor
and you say it's impossible i get it
there's a union
you know you can't go out and get three
retired guys to mow 10 hours
a week each that would be ideal like the
golf course
that would save that would save the
school district money
but and so everybody gives up because it
seems impossible
but what is the number one limiting
factor to you having better grasps it's
people
and you need to keep talking about that
and documenting it and say look
i got a trailer my stuff and a trailer
the mowers down to this other campus
with this grade school here's how much
time it takes me
simply to mow right and so everybody's
looking for a technical fix
but if you don't have the people to sit
on mowers and to do with these other
things
we're just talking junk right because
what's the number one thing you can do
mo more often okay so
you know how often is beaver stadium
here in in my background mode
three times a week sometimes four now
you know
when it's cold middle of summer maybe
it's twice but you mow often how often
you mow greens pretty much every day how
often are you mowing your high school
field
once every 10 days right maybe once a
week
and if it rains that goes to 10 days
yeah the best thing you can do
is mow twice a week that's right and
even you know what we
talk about andy is you know let's break
down a soccer field or an american
football field for example
you don't have to budget for two acres
of rye grass seed
you got a budget for gold miles hash
marks
and again to your point you need a
person to go back out
pull the air fire over those areas
sprinkle
a little bit of compost or top dressing
or sand whatever you're using
spread the seed on there drag a hose and
hit it with a spot
that kind of detail targeted at the
right spots gives you the most
value but again you know the idea
again you said it perfect ah hundred
thousand dollars again rugged i don't
have to do nothing let me take you back
to synthetic curve for a second
you say really clearly it's not a free
lunch
what are those things i know in the past
we've talked and i think you've got the
real research now to say
if you're tracking one thing and one
thing only on these synthetic surfaces
it's infill volume
do you feel the same way about that oh
absolutely it's infill depth it's the
cheapest thing you can measure
it's the easiest and it's the most
important right now um
so i mean you can get you know i i've
seen guys do it with a
with a tired uh tread depth gauge you
can get a uh
we call them uh insulation depth gauges
for like 15 bucks on amazon or 25 bucks
through mascara
right and so it's pretty simple you go
out and we have a nice spreadsheet on
our website that can help you keep track
of that to say if you're in compliance
nice yeah and hardness you know
measuring surface hardness is important
but it's directly proportional to two
things mainly infill depth
and secondarily paint buildup so if you
get a lot of paint build up you need to
get that out of there
right because that'll make the field
hard at that spot
but it's really so you know you can buy
a kleg for four thousand dollars that's
awesome and go out and do that it's
really not that big of an expense
but for 20 30 bucks you get this infill
depth gauge and you know what you're
starting at you know what the
target is because the company will give
you that go out and measure that every
couple of weeks and when it gets low
you top dress on some more or you
outsource it and hire somebody to top
dress on some more
that's the number one thing you can do
to keep the fields it increases the
longevity of the field
right these things do break down from
mechanical wear but not very quickly
it's usually a combination of uv light
and mechanical wear
so the more that thing that's buried uh
right the less of it's exposed to uv
light it's probably going to hold up
longer and we're finding that
you know it's going to make it softer
and it's going to make the traction
slightly lower
um and so you know that should benefit
the players all right
listen listen before we got we got about
five more minutes and we're going to ask
see if anybody anybody listens
got any questions or anything we'll
we'll open it up to that but
before we do that you know i think you
you were there's two things i want to
say one is
i think you're right about the people
thing you know my sense is that
there's a lot of science sitting on the
shelf of how to keep natural grass
fields
whether they're sand based or soil based
you know a functioning and you're right
it is often that one bad game that you
can't hold off
that and i can tell you playing soccer
here in central new york we we got a
sand based field and we love it because
we get
it seems like it rains every day uh
during soccer season so you're exactly
right about that
i i just want to reiterate the bmps are
a way to have access to some of that
basic science
and you're right we had to stop
somewhere you can go to our safe sports
field website other
places you guys have them there's lots
of other resources but these aren't
complicated problems right the soil gets
compacted
and blah blah blah okay so let's put
that on the shelf before i ask
for other questions andy the metlife
stadium thing brand new turf
people chirp and chirp and chirping you
don't have to answer this if you don't
want to
but what do you make of the perception
that
there are this is what's to blame
versus what you and i have just talked
about that infill that
these are knowable things there's no way
i know you you're gonna let them play on
that field if it's
you know blah blah blah it's like i'm
thinking of listening to this [ __ ] and i
was like i know the guy
that does this so you don't have to
answer
but i'm asking well what i will tell you
is
is that that field was probably more
tested prior to that game
and especially right after that game
than any field in the league has ever
been tested
um because it it passed fifa's highest
quality test
before the game occurred it passed all
the nfl um
certification processes and it was
tested two and three more times after
that
and what i can tell you is when we
compare that field across the league
in no way was that field an outlier
that's what i thought
and no field went and so look i get it
you know you lose
three high quality players in one game
early in the season
you got to blame something right
because you know your season just uh
started to tumble in front of your eyes
had it happened on natural grass unless
there were visual things that were
occurring
where the grass was coming up or
something i'm not sure the same uh
the same accusation would be made but i
will tell you
the league the players association fifa
everybody took a very very hard look at
that field
both prior because it was new um but
it was fifa you know whatever their
highest i think they changed it used to
be what two diamond
it passed their highest testing um and
it passed all the league testing and
when you compared the numbers
there was nothing uh out of the norm
with that field
so perfect okay so how about questions
carl got any questions for dr mcnitt
yeah no questions from the audience but
but i want to hit on something andy was
talking about the labor
and building in kind of that buffer time
that it takes to mobilize equipment
or to transport equipment uh how
important is that when you're
talking to the people making decisions
building in that extra time because it's
not just
the time sitting on the mower and mowing
the field it's the time
mobilizing and cleaning the equipment
how important the wrench to include
so here's here's what i tell them i
preach this to my students constantly
the people that rise to the top of the
turf industry are not necessarily the
best grass growers
they're the best communicators because
they can communicate
to the administration that holds the
purse strings their needs
they can get the funding and the people
to accomplish the job
right so what to your point carl um
yeah you need to document all of this
like look this is the man hours it takes
us to load this trailer to move it to
the elementary school to mow
you know and then uh and come back etc
all that needs to be documented
because these guys understand numbers
you know you can't expect them to come
down there and you know
figure out whatever how to uh change the
pressure plate and your throw out
bearings on your clutch right they're
not going to know that
they're not going to know anything about
that they'll be lucky if they know what
pto stands for
right so it's not their job it's not
their job
to to know your job it's your job to
talk their language
right so you must be able to talk their
language and their language is numbers
charts projections right so you need to
know down to the penny how much it costs
you to trailer that stuff
to mow over there etc so that you can
make the argument
now one of the things dave minor taught
me that i love is
um you have limited resources you don't
have enough people you don't have enough
resources
don't spread those resources evenly
across all your campuses
steal from places short places and
create
one prime field because if you don't
everything is average and the
administration is going to say if we
give this guy another
guy or two and some more maintenance
budget
everything's just going to be a little
more average
right but if you can show them what's
possible here's one field look what i
can do
right and even if you're stealing from
the other fields now they know the
potential but
two and the most important thing that i
found when i implemented mentor strategy
is
you suddenly have advocates on your
point because the people who aren't
playing on that field are saying
why does the coaches why doesn't my
field look like that
what do you need more people more people
now
all the coaches are going to the
administration saying get that guy some
more people
and so that's i think uh one strategy
that's worked pretty well i'm i'm
telling you
the whole year we won't get as many
one-liners as we got from
andy today carl i am telling you andy
what a joy to have you
i i hope we got i got a feeling we got
to talk about exactly what you wanted to
talk about
not exactly but we got a little bit of
it in there so that's good
about this lighting you guys need to do
something about this it's looking like
i'm all puffy under here and i don't
think we'll blur it out
we'll blur it out in editing you're
gonna be in you're gonna be in
you're gonna be a regular we're gonna
get you all set up don't you worry
most people are watching on news channel
three tomorrow
they were listening to the podcast
wonderful yeah send me better likes carl
but we'll send you thanks for just like
up uh for our budget next year we'll
budget for uh some makeup but uh
anyway thanks everybody for joining us
fastest 30 minutes in turk we're always
keeping it to 30 minutes again thanks
everyone for joining
we'll see you guys next week thank you
andy love you brother take care of
yourself
take it easy this has been a production
of cornell university on the web at
cornell.edu